lovely I just realized that
erbium is the most crucial element for
the internet of all the elements on the
periodic table and so I want to take you
across to materials engineering where we
can see a demonstration which will
explain to why it's so important and why
without erbium many of you couldn't be
watching this video
erbium is another lanthanide metal it's
soft silvery quite malleable very
reactive towards oxygen and water and I
suppose for us right now it's quite
significant because it was originally
discovered from a mineral which was
found in this quarry so we're in a
quarry in in Sweden near Stockholm
called it'll be mine and some black
minerals that were found in this in this
quarry actually with the birthplace for
for new chemical elements and and erbium
was one of them erbium is a a
photographic filter and it is actually a
nuclear poison what that means is that
it will kill dead any nuclear fission
process so it's ghostly got some
applications there it's an interesting
element when you make compounds of it
and dissolve it in solution it's often
pink so this is some erbium trichloride
now you'll notice it's very slightly
pink
I think this is one of the ones which
because of its pink coloration gets used
in jewelry and things like sunglasses
and things like life memory serves more
recently erbium is used as an amplifier
of light as it's transmitted down
optical fibers so the the reason we're
here and I'm all dressed up these are
the fibers that are used to transmit the
signals for the internet now the reason
they use fibers is because copper cables
which you would normally use for
electrical signals cannot carry nearly
as much information as many youtube
viewings at once as one of these fibers
and the fiber is very strong neither
bravely no I have managed to break it
and the problem is that even with this
fiber with a light beam going down it
eventually the light gets weaker and
weaker and you lose the signal so every
50 kilometers every 30 miles or so down
the fiber when it's under the sea
you have to amplify the signal to get it
back up again so that our YouTube video
can reach the other side of the Atlantic
or to India or wherever and so the way
you've got to do is you've somehow got
to amplify the light make it more
intense and you can do this with erbium
because if you put erbium into the glass
then if you shine a light onto the
erbium atoms they get excited and then
as the light comes in from the signal it
interacts with European mattum and the
erbium atoms loses its energy and gives
out more light so essentially the light
comes in and comes out twice as intense
it then keeps going another 30 miles and
you repeat it here that we've got the
infrared laser I used to work with
lasers but I've rather given up now so
but so it's quite nostalgic and is it
switched on and if you put this in the
laser beam you can see there's a special
screen here which will actually take in
red laser beam which you can't see and
make it into visible light so you can
see it we've got infrared light going
into a piece of glass with opium in it
now what is happening here is the
physics here is slightly different from
what happens in the amplifier but is
really quite fun because a light beam
that you can't see is suddenly being
changed into visible light into green
light which you can yes it's very
important I had heard about it in
lectures but when we videoed our first
video about erbium I completely
forgotten about this although without it
nobody would have seen any of our videos
welders people that join pieces of metal
together using either large electric
fields or extreme temperatures have
special masks to protect their eyes from
them the very bright light which is
given out in the welding process welding
goggles typically can include erbium
salts because they are very intense and
they absorb a massive amount of the
light so that the the eyes of the weld
are not damaged at all so under the sea
you have these fibers with copper wires
going next to it carrying the current
for the diodes that excite the
amplifiers all the way long and
apparently the current going down these
wires is quite attractive to sharks and
so in shallow water sharks come along
and see the cable and it seems
attractive and they start chewing it and
although Brady and I can't break the
fibers a shark in full spate can easily
cut through it and so they've been quite
a lot of problems with the optic fibers
in shallow water being chewed to bits by
sharks